I think that that basketball was some of  the best basketball I will ever see for  the rest of my life do you feel that way  sure I think that was the highest level  of basketball being played because it  was only basketball and guys were so  locked in this you know you go to the  gym you have shoot around you eat  play  win or lose you you're in your room and  you go back to the gym if you want some  if you want to do something you want a  hobby  you just go to the gym you have a court  time from six to nine like that was all  we did you know so I'm not really  playing cards with your teammates you  know so  um guys were just locked in I was like  we're always talking about basketball I  was talking about coverages where I was  in the gym shooting free throws um  so it was just that was the only thing  we're doing and that helped me for sure  because that's the kind of guy I am to  stay locked in night in night out